hello my name is Mary gray I'm
co-chairing with Jackie O'Neal on this
session one of the last of the day on
workers of the world connect so
hopefully you're here for that session
and we one of our panelists Louise
Hickman is remote she was stopped at
customs in Heathrow sure many of us can
feel a lot of empathy for that and many
of us probably feel deep embarrassment
for that but we have a video that she's
recorded so the flow of the day the goal
of this is to get to conversation as
quickly as possible so each of our
panelists has prepared ten minutes of
remarks and we have a few questions that
we've we've decided we'd like to start
with among the panelists and we can as
quickly as possible move to your
questions and have some discussion but
the the framing for this is that several
of us are working on kind of the
practicalities of what kinds of tools
facilitate communication conversation a
particularly thinking about mobile and
conversational agents as a way of a
promoting agency and connection among
workforces but of course that has to
take into consideration how our
workforce is radically changing they're
not in one single location they have a
range of tasks projects that are doing
all of that complexity we want to bring
to the table and think about that
complexity and not just within the
narrow scope of productivity but also
thinking about the social and political
consequences of that connection or
disconnection so with that we'll start
with Louise's presentation and then
we'll move to our other panelists we're
going to be working from from the podium
just to make things as smooth as
possible for Louise who's going to be
tuned into our conversation and she'll
join us as much as we can make that
happen through their limited AV in the
world today but our amazing AV team that
has been facilitating this for the
latter part of the session so with that
thank you in thinking about the
collaborative relationship between
real-time writers and their nurses I'm
thinking about
relationship at the site of social
exchange rather than captioning as a
consumer product or expanded I process
that provided by on-demand platforms
instead I'm thinking about captioning
I'd provided by real-time writers and
the work they do on their dictionary the
maintenance work the up key were by
maintaining contact with their deaf and
disabled users by thinking about their
work and thinking about the value of
access work how do we protect the future
of what they do and how do we maintain
the relationship between the Machine the
sonography machine and the captioning
work they do how do we embed this
relationship and to assist them think
not about automated text but thinking
about the captioning process and the
relationships that you've maintained and
established by users and worker
themselves to think about this
relationship in the context of on
demands on demand captioning services
appearing online we can think about how
this posed a threat to the work that on
real-time writers do by thinking about
this word and I I think it's interesting
that increasingly real-time were a
real-time demand it's increasingly
becoming a part of our digital lexicon
but for deaf and hard-of-hearing users
this has been around for thirty years
within the beginning of the 19th as a
result of the ADEA and section 504 so
the real-time work that scenographer do
have had been developed over the last 13
years in ways they have become
Burtie of taking spoken speech and
turning it into real-time test in ways
that they become resourceful in working
with their clients to develop a
meaningful dictionary for them to news
in classroom situations in but in this
sense today I'm really talking about the
classroom where real time were exist
across three sections of speech detect
industries and that in education
courtroom work and broadcasting and they
are interlinked in a way that they
become important to maintain the
integrity and the ethics of the work
they do so in thinking about that
relationship and thinking about the
value of access workers I very much time
trying to caution against the idea that
we can automate some store L to make
captions or some statement or work they
had an impact on the news or deaf news
and hard-of-hearing as they lose access
to worker themself recently a major
broadcasting group has shifted to new
automated pets powered by Watson
software to instead of using real-time
captioner and this had an invitation on
how and will earn deaf and
hard-of-hearing people can access
material so Thank You Louise for
starting us off and I each of the
speakers are going to give you a bit
about their own work how it connects to
the themes of this panel and then also
give you a very specific case that
they're working on to be able to put
that on the table for our discussion
today
our next speaker is James Woodcock from
Oxford University
can I do the huns three yeah
don't can you hear me now wonderful so
I'm going to speak about technology and
work which of course is ironic given I
didn't get the microphone to work at
first and what I want to talk about is
some of the ethnographic projects that I
have been part of to think about work
because I think one of the things that
has been absent from the conference in
various ways is workers we've talked a
lot about the future of work and I think
this session is the only one that
actually gestures explicitly to the fact
that work involves workers in various
ways and for the first at the graphic
project that I did I worked undercover
in a call center and now the future of
work and talking about work is a kind of
fashionable thing to be talking about
but when I did my PhD I was the only
student who wanted to talk about work
and people said to me know why would you
spend your research money talking to
workers and hanging around in a call
center when you could be doing a million
other interesting things luckily it's
become a little bit more fashionable to
talk about work and and the experience
in the call center I want to talk about
briefly and then I want to give an
example that speaks to the theme of this
session is I think call centers remain a
very important example of work to think
about when we think about the role of
Technology because for many workers in
call centers technology has been
introduced with very little ability for
workers to say this is a good idea this
is a bad idea this makes work better or
makes work worse I don't know how many
of you have ever worked in a call center
okay we've got one or two how many of us
have ever called a call center and had a
less than good experience
okay so you've had a sly insight into
what it's like working in a call center
when I worked in a call center I sold
life insurance to people who didn't want
to buy life insurance I'm not a
particularly good at selling life
insurance to people but the experience
for many workers was that everything you
did was time for the second how long
you've spent on calls how long you spent
in between calls every sale was counted
everything was digitally recorded and so
there was an intense feeling of
supervision in the workplace every
moment was expected to be productive you
were kind of constantly meant to be
finding ways to sell life insurance on a
cold call now why I think it's important
to think about these kind of examples of
call center work in the UK is broadly
considered to be bad work it has a huge
turnover people don't want to work in
this sector is I think call center work
is very important for understanding the
growth of new forms of work today so
platform work delivering food or working
for uber or so on and what I want to
give for my example is a story about a
gig worker in the UK and how they've
interacted with technology in various
ways now while I worked in a call centre
and I was eventually fired for not being
good enough for working in the call
centre but that's a whole nother story
indeed you'll gain I'm much better at
making bad jokes
with a microphone than I am at selling
life insurance and we've had a huge
growth of of platforms like uber eats in
London the most dominant one is called
delivery so this is a food delivery
platform where people either cycle or
they deliver food on a on a motorbike
now for various reasons I'm not a very
confident cyclist instead of actually
working for delivery I spent a long long
periods of time since 2016 interviewing
delivery drivers and talking to them
about their experience of work delivery
like many of these platforms is
algorithmically driven and there's very
little contact with anything like an
organizational chart at delivery and so
I started co-writing papers with a
delivery driver somebody who I'd met by
talking to when he was delivering pizza
and I think his story and many of these
workers it is his story because of the
the gendering of this kind of work I
think speaks to the experience of the
application of technology to this kind
of work so this driver had never met
anybody who worked for delivery he'd
never met an employee of the company he
arrived one day at a shipping container
in southeast London where he was given a
uniform he had the app downloaded on his
phone
and if anything ever went wrong he would
call somebody it wasn't directly
employed by the company so his
experience of the organization was very
different to what most of us might
expect he had an interest in discovering
how much he cycled what his kind of
performance was at work and whenever he
asked for performance statistics he
never got a reply and so one of the
projects that we developed was self
tracking himself as he cycled around
London trying to make sense of the
experience from his perspective seeing
you know how fast he went where he went
to the most common routes how much money
he made and so on and so we produced a
series of these large maps which maybe
this would be the point where a
PowerPoint might have been useful but
heat maps of his own performance all of
which is data that the platform had but
wouldn't give over to him and so
whenever he had contact with the
platform what they would tell him is not
you've performed five out of ten or
you've met your statistics or whatever
he was always told whether or not he had
met a performance statistic or not he
was never told whether he'd comfortably
met it he was never told by how many
seconds just this week you have met
performance metric a B C and D and so he
said the experience of this work was
very very difficult because he didn't
know whether he was meeting the targets
by one second by a minute by three
minutes or whatever it was and I think
this is a kind of interesting problem
for food delivery I don't know how many
of you want your pizza to arrive in 20
minutes exactly
usually I forget if I order something
and if it's 25 minutes it's not a big
deal for me but for this platform is an
incredible demand on making sure that
every possible second is shaved off the
delivery time and so we did a whole
series of interviews we wrote these
papers together and at one point I asked
this delivery driver what's the hardest
thing about working for a food delivery
platform and what I thought he would say
is it's hard not having a real manager
you know
it's hard not being able to to challenge
if I don't make a performance metric or
whatever it is it's hard not having a
proper employment contract you know it's
hard not having workplace rights or
whatever it is but he didn't say any of
these things and what he said I think is
a really important point about this new
kind of work is he said I get up in the
morning and I'm not really a breakfast
person okay quite sure where this is
going
so I go to my first job where I work in
a cafe and I serve people coffee on
their way to work it gets the lunchtime
I try and have a quick snack and then I
deliver other people's food over
lunchtime I then go back to working my
third job where I try successfully and
unsuccessfully to sell people books in a
bookshop so they get to the end of my
shift and I try and have some kind of
snack and then I deliver other people's
food for the rest of the evening he said
the hardest thing is once I've done all
of that cycling and worked all of those
jobs is when I get home having enough
energy to cook enough calories that I
can repeat the entire process again the
next day and I think in a sense when we
think of these platforms whether it's
uber or delivery we can often think
about the technological innovations of
algorithmically driven demand of
scheduling and so on we can think of the
kind of technology that's used to it but
what that driver said is a damning
indictment that the majority of his
customers are workers who are too tired
to cook their own food we have very very
glossy marketing in the UK of delivery
will bring you crushed avocado on toast
and sushi for your millennial lifestyle
in central London the reality is it's
mostly cheap food for workers who are
tired he says that the major problem for
him is to deliver calories to people who
are too tired that it makes him too
tired to eat himself and I think the
reason I tell this story is to remind
people that when we talk about work and
we talk about the future of work this
has impacts and implications for the
people that do it and particularly when
we talk about productivity if you see a
map of different points drivers and
customers and restaurants and they
about how to optimize that in various
ways what that means for the person
that's delivering the food is higher
risk of road traffic accidents being
more tired on their way home all to
shave one or two minutes off a delivery
time and so I think when we have these
kind of discussions and think about
technology we have to think about the
way that technology is enacted in
practice in various ways and what I want
to finish on is to talk about how this
driver along with many other drivers has
used technology themselves to think
about how they can reorient a a platform
like this
I'm never entirely sure how popular
whatsapp is in in the US but in the UK
it's fairly ubiquitous particularly with
migrant communities which make up many
of the drivers on these platforms and
when I asked this driver do you speak to
other people in your workplace you know
they're kind of in the city said of
course I do let me invite you to one of
these whatsapp groups with three or four
hundred drivers in the neighborhood
sharing experiences about the best
restaurants to wait outside and so on is
in amongst the kind of gaps in the
algorithms of these platforms workers
find new uses for technology and often
those are to push back against the worst
aspects of these platforms but they also
give us the possibility of imagining how
technology could be used in very very
different ways thank you very much
Thank You Jamie
Jackie O'Neill from Microsoft research
versus is our next speaker
I do can you hear me is my mic on I know
yeah okay so I'm Jackie O'Neill I'm an
ethnographer at Microsoft Research in
India and my research interest is
thinking about how we can design
technology to help people have better
working lives I have a focus on the
global south but not only on the global
south and the topic of this workshop is
very close or this panel is very close
to my heart
I've been studying gig where crowd work
and informal economies since 2011 and
I've been designing workplace technology
that hopefully fits with workers
practice for much longer than that so it
was great actually that they became
before me because I want to talk about
two parallel workplace trends that we
see transforming the world of work the
first is the adoption of chat has a
workplace tool and the second is the
rise of the platform economy so if you
don't see a connection bear with me I'm
hopefully going to draw one so workplace
adoption of chat WeChat what's up are
becoming almost as ubiquitous as the
smartphone's on which they run and one
of the really interesting things is that
we see workers using them they are
widely used by many of the 2.7 billion
workers who don't work in offices they
work in transportation they work in
retail they work in agriculture
healthcare government banking all of
these things and I'm going to talk about
two trends in the adoption of chat in
the workplace the first is that chats
often chat adoption is often worker
driven which is something that really
intrigues me as a workplace technology
specialist and my studies of
King government where healthcare show
that people are adopted for the
workplace because it's lightweight its
flexible its mobile and very crucially
it's easily to be easy to understand and
to adapt to the local needs of
non-technical people it doesn't require
much of a ramp up much of a learning
curve because most people are actually
using it already for their personal
lives so they can just adapt it to their
work lives and then what's really
interesting you can send text messages
you can send voice messages you can send
photos now of course you can take a
photo pretty much anything you can take
a photo of a handwritten paper document
you can take a photo of a typed document
you can take a photo of a screen you can
take a photo of some plants in a field
you can take a photo of yourself and you
can also share videos and documents and
links it is amazing what type of
workflows you can construct from these
pieces and it supports just-in-time
workflow so you're on the move you're
out and about you can send a message
right there and then you don't have to
wait you get to a desktop and many of
the workers I work with don't even have
a desktop and one of the things that we
find is that it's the glue chat is often
the glue that sticks together diverse
systems which can be paper and can be
digital but which don't talk to one
another and they're often not flexible
enough to fit the needs of the workers
and it's 60 systems together with their
diverse work practices of highly mobile
time pressed workers so that's the first
chat trend the second one is that chat
is being adopted as a way of supporting
new organizational forms so if you're
thinking about providing how you want to
provide services well needed services to
rural people in the global South quite
often the companies that do this have to
create very innovative organizational
forms they have high
distributed workforces and new business
models so I want to give you the example
here of well told story now well told
story is a youth empowerment magazine
it's created by a small to small teams
one in Nairobi and one in Daraa Salaam
and it tells stories to get across
important messages from financial
literacy to sexual health and it has
over 1 million subscribers this is a
monthly magazine they could not survive
without their network of 3,000
distributors
these distributors don't work for them
ok they are small local entrepreneurs
young people basically with small
businesses all over Tanzania and Kenya
you might it might be a barber shop it
might be a cafe and basically they stock
the magazine for free they don't get
paid for this partly to support youth
empowerment and partly to increase
football through their business and then
the other thing that well told story
does is it has to take the pulse of
young people regularly through surveys
and the problem with this is if you've
got people all over Kenya and people all
over Tanzania distance is a barrier and
increases costs so one thing that we're
doing is that they're managing this
distributed ecosystem because they've
adopted chat tools which have
programmable api's so they're creating
new workflows and new ways to
communicate so this can be talking to
their distributors and engaging their
customers and it's really interesting to
see these highly innovative
organizations managing to get services
across countries like this so now I want
to move on to the second workplace trend
which is the rise of the platform
economy I've been studying crowd work
through I am as a Mechanical Turk in the
US and India and platform work physical
work such as ride-sharing this is Ola
India's uber and what she studied uber
in India now digital work and physical
work are really quite different there
different types of work and they have
different workforces but what's really
interesting is when they're mediated by
a platform and they're managed
algorithmically there's a remarkably
consistent worker experience now myself
and people at this table and many people
in this room have documented very well
some of the challenges for workers of
working on these platform economies so I
just want to highlight a few of them
briefly so the first is the platform
acts as a digital middleman so it's in
the middle between the customers all the
people with the work and the people
doing the work and it arose independence
because you can no longer negotiate
about your jobs most of these platforms
deliberately design collaboration out of
the workplace but work still collaborate
and we see networks of digital and
physical networks of colleagues who help
and support one another such as your
whatsapp group of workers for delivery
and of course algorithmic management
treats all workers as interchangeable
units distinguished only by their
ratings whereas of course we know that
individual people have individual skills
and talents and requirements so we have
two trends on the one side we have the
rather positive trend which is that
we're seeing lightweight mobile tools
being adopted by work workers to support
their practices and supporting new
organizational forms that can provide
services that adapt to local needs often
in extreme circumstances on the other
hand we have a rather negative trend
which is the rise of the platform
economy which certainly provides jobs
and customer value however the way that
platforms are currently designed tends
to be adversarial and doesn't really
benefit the workers but it doesn't have
to be this way we can think of creative
ways of bringing these two trends
together to create a better future at
work so I want to talk about two
just very very briefly as its just my
position statement I could go on for
hours of course two small trends that we
should think about one is thinking about
how we might empower workers because we
can't rely on the platforms to do it but
the second is we should also think about
how we can design better platforms well
some of the bigger players might never
be going to change their work practices
or care about their workers there are
lots of smaller platforms out there
which really do care about their workers
if only they could think about how they
could be designed better so if we think
about empowering workers and go and
beyond the platform we can think about
ways we might use chat to create a
connected workforce so building the
relationships back between the workers
and this is important for friendship
motivation technical troubleshooting
collaboration support it's so important
for so many things and when we augment
chat with programmable api's we can
think about how we might build worker
platforms and worker centric platforms
that enable workers to connect in
communities of practice but also
geographic communities and we can these
platforms can be used for reporting
grievances and supporting collective
action and also for enabling workers to
organize to get together to work
together in more flexible ways than the
current platform economy allows and then
the second one is we can think about how
we design better platforms and basically
you could quite simply start designing
chat into these platforms themselves it
doesn't have to be a separate thing and
we can do this to build the relationship
back between the employers or customers
and the workers this might be long term
in crowd work you might actually want to
have a long term engagement with your
workers and we actually saw an Amazon
Mechanical Turk people worked around amt
to have long term relationships with
their workers or in physical work it
might just be for a short time you're
just coming together to get a service
done you might want to talk about it it
also can be used to build relationships
between the platforms and platforms and
the workers
platforms tend to be rather opaque and
unapproachable and you could think about
how you could have facilitated chat
groups to offer both peer support and to
reduce the adversarial relationship
between the platform in the workers and
finally to build relationships between
the workers for all the reasons we
talked about on the previous slide so I
hope that I've shown you some ideas for
how we can think about building a more
positive future thank you
[Applause]
and in some ways I'm going to I'm
hitting a drum beat here that you're
hearing across all of the presentations
and I'm I'm going to just selfishly plug
this book in the co-author with
Siddharth Suri but mostly I'm going to
pull some very specific findings from
the book to be able to cue up thinking
about this connection but also to frame
it within what are the challenges of
connection alone and where we need to
shore up how we're thinking about
fostering identification and collective
action what would that look like
so connection beyond connection
collaboration that that's meaningful and
recognized and you can't really do
research like this without not without
feeling incredibly indebted to the
hundreds of people who gave time to be
able to share their experiences let us
into their homes the thousands of people
who did surveys across the four
platforms that we studied and two
countries and it was really very much an
interdisciplinary team effort so I do
want to clear the the weeds here what do
we mean by ghost work the term itself is
actually meant to point to the work
conditions it's not the workers
themselves workers are quite aware of
each other is to say what is it that
we're doing when we create work that's
not just a niche job if we think about
the design of on-demand labor but rather
see it as the dismantlement of full-time
employment so right now we tend to talk
about these kinds of platform ad ization
on-demand jobs as specific kinds of jobs
rather than what does it look like to
orient to work that's project driven
project specific and at this point
defined by contracts short contracts
that can be seconds or minutes or hours
or months but the expectation is that
they end because they're oriented around
teams of people coming to a project this
might be a familiar map for how does
this work how does this on demand work
work but think about it in this somewhat
static two-sided market with an
intermediary and imagine all of the
kinds of businesses that can coerce
through connect
ding at least in part this task a
task-based contractor and work that can
at least in part so a source schedule
managed ship and bill a project that can
course through the internet and an api
now if you use that framework that's a
lot of different work that's most of the
kinds of work we do in this room it can
be it can be teaching it can be writing
it can be event planning it can be AV
work it can be anything that's involving
the kind of deliberative spontaneous
actions that people do today and being
able to match it with this approach
that's quite profoundly I would argue
revolutionary about how it can orient
people to projects
it doesn't say go into an office and do
a thing it says I have this project
who's coming that's a very different
orientation to work and with a different
orientation to work the invitation of
all of these platform approaches is to
say all comers what we found across all
four platforms and this is fairly common
in platform economies but also in
citizen science or any approach that's
task based open call is that there's a
good core group we called them always on
again this is across all the platforms
they're the folks there's a good core
group that are doing most of the work
they're picking most of the projects up
that wasn't distinctive about Amazon
Mechanical Turk or universal human
relevant system or Lee genius or Maura
or any of the other companies we looked
at there was a core group that was doing
this work hold in mind that often we
might think of these as full-time
workers full-time employees and much of
the mantra is can't we get everybody
into the category of always-on well the
reality is there's a good 20 percent ish
and I'm this is clearly not to scale Sid
might not particularly appreciate this
graphic but there's a good core group of
folks regulars who have picked a time or
a number of tasks or a particular kind
of set of projects that they go to
routinely they have a way in which
they're turning this
work an income stream into something
they can count on they're importantly
the deep bench that is there so when
anybody who's always on steps away those
folks can step in and no consumer will
ever be able to tell the difference one
way we narrate that now is that people
are interchangeable I think the other
paradigm we can use is that the capacity
for humans to be able to pick up
something spontaneously and step into
somebody's else and somebody else's
shoes to evaluate what do I need to do
next that's distinctly human we don't
have a way of modeling that we don't
have priors this is the technically hard
thing that a human is doing within any
process that's meant to capitalize on
humans in the loop and then there's this
long tail of experimentalists who are
trying things out they might do one
project they they literally do one
project and say peace out this is awful
or they've figured there's something
else they want to try on a different
platform
there's myriad reasons people are coming
to this approach to picking a project
based work and being paid for it there
isn't one kind of worker here and that's
important but importantly for this
approach to task based work there isn't
a version of this that can survive where
everybody is always on or everybody's
irregular or everybody's an
experimentalist we didn't find a version
of this where this worked without this
this distribution without this profile
and an argument for why that's true is
precisely because the range of
motivations the mix of people and
circumstances and contexts in which
people are coming to this work is
precisely what allows them to enter the
doors and experimentalist test something
out this is the pipeline to becoming
somebody who's always on but importantly
everybody in this mix they are
organizing life around work in other
circumstances in this setting they get
to organize work around their lives if
there was one thing in common it was
everybody is searching for the capacity
not for flexibility and I
encouraged and some of you have heard me
say this before please stop using the
word flexibility to describe this work
this is a way of managing constraints on
my life I could choose work where I can
step into this work try out projects and
there are other motivations I'll mention
in a moment but this organization of
work around projects is precisely what
allows people to be able to make
decisions about how to manage other
constraints in their lives that's that's
the part that's the hardest for us when
we're designing platforms to consider we
will never know the circumstances under
which somebody is trying to control
particular constraints designing for
that high dimensional variation the
heterogeneity here is the technical
challenge that Pareto distribution means
that it's creating a lot of different
mental maps for what it is that people
are doing so when I asked folks can you
describe what you do to other people
I can hear responses in the US that
range from I work for a start-up in
Silicon Valley or I'm self-employed I'm
building my skills or from someone in
India I'm an entrepreneur I'm bringing
jobs to my village and they're all
working on the same platform doing the
exact same types of tasks so importantly
this range of mental models means they
don't share a common identity as workers
we're of the same kind of worker and
anybodies as a student who's a student
of social movement and social social
action knows social movement begins with
having a shared identity a sense of a
shared common cause that is
fundamentally the first thing you build
when you're doing organizing do we see
each other as kindred and kind or
sharing a particular need until that's
in place it's very difficult to organize
around a common cause these these folks
are doing work they don't identify as
the same type of worker so when they
connect and they do connect and this is
certainly speaking to to Jacky some of
Jackie's earlier work to what Jamie was
discussing this is one example of a mod
that we built of workers on Amazon
Mechanical Turk connecting the
coloration that you see are the
different sub communities of Amazon
METEC mechanical work workers who had
built their own discussion forums and
different ways of connecting but people
were also the number of points you see
our Singleton's of folks who are those
experimentalists those regulars who
don't necessarily pipe into a specific
sub forum or sub community but folks are
also connecting via text they're hanging
out on skype working together to get
through night shifts of their own their
own setting so people do collaborate
what we found were the folks who are
most densely collabora connected and
collaborating who had perhaps the
greatest potential for forming
identities around collective action and
common cause we're the ones who are
always on that 10% they're heavily
invested in what they're doing and they
know that if they connect they're gonna
be able to share costs they'll be able
to reduce their own costs of identifying
bad actors of being able to get good
recommendations for how to do the work
they're doing of literally just having
somebody else say good job like folks
were turning to each other for that
fundamental not technical need for
connecting a deeply social need for
connecting technology will not fix or
replace the social need for connecting
so how would technology be a part of
facilitating that and perhaps
identifying places where folks have not
connected what are the on-ramps to those
connections that are meaningful to them
that are not the equivalent of the boss
building a break room where they say
please use my break room it turns out
most folks were creating their own
channels even when in the circumstances
of the two companies we studied that did
build in structured engineered
communication workers of course went and
built their own ways of connecting so
how do we facilitate that recognize it
respect it and stop trying to engineer
it out so the key takeaways for thinking
about the ways in which of
the workers could connect and how we
could facilitate it as technologist is
to work with the assumption there is no
single worksite I think one of the
greatest challenges we face today is
most of our tooling that we build tends
to work from the starting point of I've
got a shared work site and we all have a
way of authenticating each other's
identities and I trust you from the
beginning go and in this world it's
building with the opposite assumption I
don't know you yet I might not know you
for very long we're about to work on a
project go we're literally doing the
opposite still because it's easier
technically to build say a communication
system that assumes everybody's on the
same organization hypothetically teams
for example just a critique a product
that Microsoft recently built to assume
there's no sole employer of record that
most of the workers orienting the
projects there's multiple projects so I
don't have a single client and it's it's
quite dizzying to imagine a platform as
the employer that's not obviously the
case in some cases it might be true and
we could more easily deal with a
question of say an uber is it the
employer of record should everybody be
identified as the and classified as an
employee if they work for uber I think
in some ways we'd be able to see a much
more revolutionary shift if all of us
recognize if you're using uber you're
you're you're the employer of record
what are your responsibilities to that
driver you're their client and we
haven't moved there yet as consumers of
these products that deeply benefit from
the activities of myriad workers will
never see will never mean importantly
there's no unifying professional
identity or career yet so you could
imagine say something like content
moderation which was something we were
also looking at within this mix because
that's in the portfolio of work that
on-demand workers do that content review
and moderation is surfacing as a
profession what does it mean to support
that identity even if done
on a freelancing basis what would it
look like for us to facilitate that is
it certification what are the ways in
which there would be for professional
communities that organize around that
kind of work but without professional
identity it is very difficult to
organise a labour work site condition
you have to have folks who are the point
of reference for well what does it mean
to treat academics professionally what
do they usually get per salary for
office space without that point of
reference work conditions are owed and
this is a global network for a lot of
the work we're talking about
particularly if it involves information
services and knowledge work there's
quite a bit of localization happening so
the real value isn't the offshoring of
the work is that I have somebody who has
the cultural and linguistic chops to be
able to help me develop a product or a
service that's going to be in their
language in their location
serving somebody on the ground in that
spot so it's contending with this is no
longer the familiar and perhaps ugly
world of labor arbitrage where it's
about how do I reduce my labor costs by
moving it over there it is recognizing
their emerging markets that are now paid
differentially for the same type of
labour how are we going to contend with
that when workers themselves can see
when they're being paid less than
another national workforce and they're
calling the question on a wire we paid
differently so the thing I would like to
leave us with and then move into our Q&A
is to think about how we would approach
connecting worlds of workers as a
commons not as individuals who are
invested in and selfishly possessed by a
single employer but that we're
facilitating a way of tending this
commons and connecting a commons of
workers who are oriented to projects and
tasks that are in fundamental ways now
facilitated not just by algorithm
algorithmic management management but by
technical systems that are
effectively they are conduits to each
other to their forms of income and to
their forms of advocacy so with that let
me end there bring us all up if I could
and we'll bring Louise into the
conversation
[Applause]